en escenas de terror en taipei la
capital de taiwán simulan lo que sería
una guerra unas 8000 personas participan
en un ejercicio militar de una semana en
taipei un evento anual que se lleva a
cabo desde 1984
los ejercicios de este año son
escenarios similares a la guerra entre
rusia y ucrania simulaciones de china
atacando también los simulacros de este
año han adquirido una mayor importancia
en medio de crecientes temores de que el
país pueda ser atacado por su poderoso
vecino comunista china al otro lado del
estrecho beijing y reclama como propia
la isla y no descarta el uso de la
fuerza para tomar su control los canales
de noticias taiwaneses han comparado la
situación de taiwán con ucrania por
temores a las intenciones del presidente
chino xi jinping hacia taiwán
desde el comienzo de la guerra todo el
mundo dice hoy es ucrania pero mañana
está igual
si estalla una guerra entre china y
taiwán la comunidad internacional sólo
toma sanciones económicas no será
suficiente que sucederá
ahora es mucho más común que los civiles
tomen capacitaciones en defensa civil
aquí las personas aprenden a ubicar
refugios de emergencia y brindar
primeros auxilios e incluso pelear en
tumbar gobierno de la ciudad de taipei
dijo que el propósito de los simulacros
era enseñar al público la ubicación de
los refugios antiaéreos en caso de una
eventual guerra eeuu y taiwán han
advertido que beijing ha estado
ejerciendo una creciente presión militar
sobre la y